Um, well, I think we should start the story on June 25th,
1969 or first you should see who you are. MCZ Lichtenberg I'm Janet. I'm Rod.
This is more perfect. Okay. So why, uh, why June 20? When was it?
June 25th, 1969 y then, uh,
Supreme Court Chief Justice Earl Warren is retiring.
Earl Warren of the Warren Court. Big Court. Yeah. That's really,
no, come on. Humor me. I think if you think of legendary Supreme Court justices,
he's probably in, I don't know, the top five.
So he was one of the Mountain Olympians. He's a big deal. Right? All right.
He's retiring. He's retiring.
He's been on the court for 16 years and he's in an interview and he's asked,
how would you list Mr Chief justice as the supreme court's most important
decision in your 16 years here?
And he says something that is kind of astounding.
I think the a reapportionment not only of state legislatures by Porsche
before you hear the answer. I think that you need to know that, um,
he could have said all kinds of cases. He was the chief justice during,
during the interim. I don't know if Miranda,
either of his rights to remain silent. That's,
you have the right to remain silent. Oh,
Clarence Earl Gideon petition
or Gideon versus Wainwright.
It is the beauty of the space,
which is you have the right to an attorney that seems big or has no place in our
democracy. Brown vs board of Education. Okay. There was no better place.
And I know that one. I know desegregating the schools. That's big. Yeah.
What could be bigger than that? He doesn't say any of those. What does he say?
He says this little case called
the baker versus Carr case. Baker versus Carr. Huh.
I think that, uh,
that that case is perhaps the most important case that we've had since I've been
on the court.
You thought that case, whatever it is,
is more important than the case that desegregated the schools. You did. Wow.
So what the hell is it exactly? No, really what is it?
It's this case that was so dramatic and so traumatic that it apparently broke
two justices. There was an instance in which my, uh,
brother found my father going upstairs to get a shotgun. Wow.
More purple.
The honorable,
the chief justice and the associate justices of the Supreme Court of the United
States. All. Yay. Yay.
Yeah. The brain quantum United.
Your favorite money to draw and Aaron get very tight is now
vulnerable card.
[inaudible].
Okay. So this is more of perfect a mini series
about the supreme court.
And just to frame the story we're about to hear for a second,
as we were putting the show together, um,
we hosted a panel discussion and a couple of us were on stage and a woman in the
audience asked the following question. Oh yes. Could you, um,
address what I see is the, uh,
increasing politicization of the court, the apotheosis of which I guess was,
uh, you know,
voting or electing Bush to be our president.
Has the court always been this way?
Is this just my perception that it's becoming more politicized?
So this turns out to be a really interesting question. Uh, it turns out
I didn't know this until Susie started looking into it,
that there was a moment when the Pandora's box just got ripped open.
So I think to understand that moment in this story,
you have to get to know three characters and these aren't necessarily the three
most important justices of all time because at that time you had Chief Justice
Earl Warren [inaudible] and William Brennan on the court.
And these are kind of giants of the Supreme Court. Gotcha. But for this story,
these three guys are key. One of them is on the right,
one of them is on the left and one of them is just stuck right in the middle,
tragically in the middle. So on the conservative side,
Ryan, what difference does it make when it in the constitution or in any other
expression or action by the state?
You had a guy named Felix Frankfurter.
So Justice Frankfurter was one of the most, is really,
his name was really frankfurter. Yes.
One of the most influential justices of all time. That's Tara Grove.
She teaches constitutional law at William and Mary Law School. Um,
he was a very influential scholar at Harvard law school before he became a
justice, was a close advisor to Franklin Delano Roosevelt. Um,
he was extremely smart, towering figure,
but as a person just as friends, just as frankfurter,
he wasn't necessarily the nicest person. I heard that from everyone I talk to.
I always call him a Bantam Rooster. Uh, he was a difficult crusty figure.
He was short, a little bit of a pouch on him.
It was one of the most condescending egotistical of justices.
He was a tough customer when a,
when a clerk would come to the u s supreme court chambers to deliver a message
and the person at the door tried to hand justice frankfurter the paper,
Frankfurter would inevitably let it drop to the ground.
So the person had to bend down and pick it up to hand it to him again.
Dude, that's a Wainer. And by the way,
the voices you heard besides Tara Grove are professors. Mike Sidemen,
Georgetown University Law Center. Sam is that girl from [inaudible] school.
Craig Smith, California University of Pennsylvania and x Supreme Court clerk.
Alan Cohen, Cohn Home KLA Chan. Okay,
so frankfurter is on one side of the aisle and his nemesis is a gentleman on the
other side of the island,
a liberal named William O. Douglas.
Here is Justice Douglas. Now the Supreme Court chambers.
This is a recording from a 1957 interview with Justice Douglas.
It looks very well as a face as 10 rugged. His eyes sparkle.
Douglas was this mountain climbing environmentalist, Vegan civil liberties.
Finally,
the oncoming generation is more aware of the importance of deliberate Pratt
generation. Whoa,
Justice Frankfurter Douglas was a prick
to everybody around him. Everybody hated him.
All those same adjectives on the sending, egotistical,
abrasive applied. Here's how the New York Times described him.
I habitual a womanizer, a heavy drinker, and uncaring parents.
Douglas was married four times cheating on each of his first three wives with
her eventual successor to do, to be a believer in kissing your bride, sir.
Oh, sure. Do you mind,
this is footage from his last marriage to his wife, Kathleen.
He was 67 she was 22
Oh yes.
So yes, yes, that is. That is William Douglas. So you have these two guys.
Frankfurter or the Bantam Rooster Douglas the prick. And as you can imagine,
they hated each other. They just despised each other.
So Frankfurter had this habit of monologuing and while he would go on and on,
Douglas would just pull out a book right in front of him and just start
reading. You know, he was just opening his disdain for Frankfurter.
I actually found a series of interviews that were done with Douglas in the early
sixties where he basically calls frankfurter names.
No, see evil, utterly dishonest.
Intellectually. He was very, very devious.
He spent his time go left down the holes,
putting poisons in everybody's Sproul.
Wow. Why did they hate each other so much? Well, according to Mike Seidman,
some of that comes from maybe their difference in background.
Frank footer was a Jewish immigrant from Austria.
A Douglas was a westerner,
but according to him, the core of their hatred actually was ideological naked
reflected a really important split
over how powerful the court should be. Though for frank footer,
courts just ought not to intervene.
He believed that in many matters should be left up to the political process and
the courts, you should stay out of those issues.
It's Douglas. Um, he thought just the opposite.
He thought that courts want to intervene to protect, for example,
minority groups, free speech rights, things of that sort.
So you had this personal feud going.
You had this ideological war that was brewing in the court and into the middle
of all this
Lux, Charles, whatever you might call them, the swing vote.
Okay, this is Alan Colton. I was a supreme court clerk for
justice Whitaker from 1957 to 1950.
Kate Whitaker grew up in a small town in Kansas called Troy.
The activist is a flashy, this is his granddaughter, kicked your Tena,
kind of a one room schoolhouse verbally a little red schoolhouse,
worked on the farm, but he, he,
he determined that was not the life for him. Kate says when he was around 16,
he became obsessed with the idea of becoming a lawyer and she says he would
actually practiced law to the animals. Can you imagine, you know,
pushing the plow along in the fields and then lecturing and arguing cases to the
cows or to the horses or whatever. Did you really hear the,
he was lecturing dude. Yes. Oh, and on the side,
which he would hunt, he would hunt squirrels,
awesome. Raccoons skunks,
and he'd sell the pelts for a few dollars and he amassed I think $700 with that
money you put himself through law school.
My understanding is that he's simultaneously went to law school and high school,
which is just mind boggling, but yeah,
apparently he went to the head of the law school in Kansas City and he's like,
I don't have a high school diploma, but you need to let me in.
The Dean just saw how ambitious he was and he was impressed and he's like,
all right, you're in. I love this guy. He's like, Mr bootstraps.
Totally any how to make a long story short,
Shawnee became a top lawyer and Alan Cohen says that's because he would do
better than all of his opponents. He would outwork them out, prepare them,
great attention to detail, great presence. Before a jury
and then he becomes a judge. First,
a federal district judge and then an appeals court judge.
Then in February of 1957 he gets the call.
Carla was in the evening and they asked if he could be in Washington in the next
morning.
This is Kent Whitaker, Charles Whittaker son. He should certainly,
but my best blue shoot deals at the cleaners tonight. What did he where I,
as a matter of fact,
my mother or someone else got the cleaners to open up at night
in the first
[inaudible] allegation tending to show that the corporation's right dog exercise
of free will let them destroy it.
This is one of the first times that Whitaker spoke on the bench and he
interjects with a question for the attorney and he is very Midwestern polite.
Yes. I guess Dave, you had so many interruptions,
but I have a question or two.
I wonder if I might have the privilege of asking sir. I think
the thing that's crazy to me is that he walked into the highest court in the
land and he didn't even go to [inaudible]
college.
I think it's important to understand that he had no formal education really.
In other words,
he never took history or political science or social science,
but he loved the law. My father was not an ideologue.
He expected the court to be an arena in which there were lively arguments on
legal issues and that's what he enjoyed.
What he was really good at, what he, what he loved
as Ken Whittaker Puts It,
his dad was kind of the walking embodiment of that thing that chief justice John
Roberts said back in 2005 during his confirmation,
Mr Chairman, I come before the committee with no agenda.
He was sort of a blank slate.
It's my job to call balls and strikes and not to pitch or bat.
My father was not interested in advancing a cause or a fury,
but frankly that seems how a justice should be,
that you're approaching it without a political agenda and you're deciding it.
I think in theory that's exactly right,
but in practice, so many of their cases,
there is no law to turn to to decide those cases.
Ken says his dad quickly discovered that law, the Supreme Court is never clean.
Cut cases make it there precisely because the law isn't clear.
Many of their cases are just without pressured them and it's in those cases,
at least you have must have.
Your ideology is a as a starting point
and the fact that he didn't have an ideology that left him vulnerable,
he was definitely getting lobbied from both sides Frankford or on one side,
Douglas on the other.
You were the new kid on the block and was being pulled by each one.
He didn't like the way the judges bullied for votes
within his first three months.
He found himself in the middle of a death penalty case.
She was found in her bedroom by firemen taken out so soon thereafter pronounced
that
a guy who had been tried for arson and murder and Douglas and the liberals
wanted to intervene to help him.
They felt like he'd been treated unfairly by the lower courts,
but frankfurter in the Conservatives thought that the supreme court should be
cautious. They should honor precedent. Now, according to Justice Douglas,
justice Whitaker was undecided all the time. Um,
Douglas would tell him one thing, oh, well, yeah, that seems right.
And then just as frank herder would say something else and you say, oh gosh,
that sounds right. I think there was some thought that, yeah,
he might side with the guy who talked with him last, you know,
he ends up being so undecided on this death penalty case that he forces the
court to delay the vote until the next term.
And there were a series of cases like this. Robert knew
where the law would be fuzzy ideologies would harden and Whitaker,
he would be right in the middle.
The physical depictions of him in that first year from people who saw him,
uh, described somebody who was restless,
terribly unhappy. I had lost a lot of weight.
Nervous was agitated most of the time. It was a lot of stress on him.
I mean,
I said this was just quicker that in normal course on the California procedure
at the minute,
but over the next few years, he bounces back. He finds his feet.
You say that judgment on probation,
his production increased
in his third year, his fourth year and part of his fifth year.
He wrote as many opinions at it as any other judge.
He wrote as many dissenting opinions as any other judge.
He was one of the nine he was fully employed and he wrote some very important
opinions during that period of time.
Along came a baker versus Carr and it broke him.
[inaudible] it's coming up.
He's from Washington from snap, snap, duck live,
watched Nashville Wyman theater flooding March 16th and I'm bringing the best in
the world. Fry laughs a more amazing night out and yes,
she's coming. The funniest woman in the world. Jen Kober.
I do my hung in the lady forest. Jen POBA rocks a brand new story.
Dick tickets it snap judgment. That'll watch you.
I've never gotten applause for it before. If you guys could call my mom,
that'd be awesome. She's still pissed.
Hey, this is more perfect.
I'm Jad Abumrad let's get back to our story from Susie Lichtenberg about the
case that broke two justices.
Number 103 trade Charles W. Baker at out.
But tell a balance versus Joe shake car and a half.
Okay, so it's April 19th, 1961
the lion is chief justice man, please. The court,
the supreme court is hearing Baker versus Carr.
Yes.
It is an individual voting rights case rotten by 11 qualified voters in the
state of Tennessee.
Now on the surface Baker versus Carr was about districts and how people are
counted in this country.
And this is one of the most basic ways that political power gets assigned in
America. Yeah. Like you know, as populations grow in size,
that growth should be reflected in the number of Congress people that are
representing them. But at that time in Tennessee,
Tennessee hadn't changed its legislative districts.
The rear one in 19 and one
since 1901 which was 60 years earlier. Well,
this created big problems for urban areas like Memphis because in those 60 years
people had moved to the cities in droves and rural areas were getting smaller.
But the Tennessee state legislature had refused to update its count and it was
still giving more representation to those rural areas in Tennessee.
Um, the figure was 23 to one,
NYU law professor Sam is that girl for people that don't understand it,
how does it actually dilute your vote? Well, I mean this is very simple.
You have one district that, uh,
one person in it and you have another district that has 23 people in it.
The district that has one person gives all the power to that one person,
the district that has 23 people, uh,
spreads it out over all 23. Wait,
all right, think of it this way. At that time,
a person in the city in Tennessee had one 23rd as much of a voice in the
legislature as a person living in the countryside.
And heres sort of the insidious underbelly of that,
it just so happened that the people living in the countryside or mostly white
and a large percentage of the people living in the city were black.
Underlying all of the reapportionment litigation, at least in the south,
was white supremacy.
That's Doug Smith historian and the author of on Democracy's doorstep.
This is deeply tied to white supremacy in the maintenance of Jim Crow,
who was a method of making sure that rural white legislatures continued to
control the power structure.
So you had this situation, he says were a small minority,
was choking the majority,
choking the the cities and the growing suburban areas from any sort of any sorts
of funds.
The cities couldn't get the money they needed for roads, education,
social services. So the question at the supreme court was,
and they would actually tackle this in two separate hearings,
what should they do about this,
Karen? You have the radical Devon
and here's where you get to the ideological smackdown liberals on the court,
like Douglas basically agreed with the plaintiff when they are.
I say there's nothing in there.
Congregational United States of America that aren't and nothing in the
constitution of the Tet of Tennessee that are days that state government must
remain an agricultural commodity.
And there's nothing in either one of those kinds of traditions is said it takes
20 city residents to equal one farm.
Liberals were like, yeah, this is clearly an injustice.
People in the cities are getting screwed.
Their voting rights have been alluded in debates to the point of nullification.
Well the conservatives are like, yes,
people are getting hurt but we're not going to do anything about it. We can't.
Frankfurter
it may affect a rotten habituation. Doesn't mean a cold today.
Most vociferously said we cannot get involved in that. As bad as it is,
there was not an issue that the court should get involved in. Why now?
I do have to think of the road that I'm going on.
What kind of road you inviting me?
He was like, think of where this will lead
littering the fact that this is unique and it's the situation.
This is a unique Tennessee situation.
If we ended up doing this in Tennessee,
pretty soon we'll be intervening in California, Maryland, South Carolina.
Pretty soon we'll be rewriting the entire US legislative map
cause they come a lot of states and not say this is just fantasy for me.
This is the United States, not Tennessee.
Yeah. So basically he felt like this would force the courts to get involved in
politics.
And he really believed that the court should never ever get involved in
politics. This is a, this is an idea that goes way back.
Something called the political question doctrine, political question doctrine.
The political question doctrine says,
no federal court can decide this issue at all.
The courts simply had no business getting into what were considered to be
fundamentally political questions.
And what could be more fundamentally political than the makeup of a legislature.
It's a philosophy rooted in the notion that unelected lifetime judges should not
be substituting their will for the will of the people's elected representatives.
Frankfurter or felt like even if you have a terrible political situation,
if the justice has stepped in and overruled the legislature,
that would be worse than doing nothing at all because it would be fundamentally
undemocratic. Um, he viewed,
he viewed the political question doctrine is a crucial limitation on the federal
judicial power. And he wasn't alone.
The courts had followed this guideline for about 150 years.
And even with the current case in Tennessee,
the federal court that first heard the case recognized the situation and
actually referred to it as an evil.
The evil is a serious one,
but should be corrected without further delay and flow.
All right. You said that this is a, this is a political question.
Malapportionment is a political question and only the political branches can
handle this, right?
Of course,
they have no power to do anything about protecting and enforcing the voting
rights of these plaintiffs.
So when the lawyer for Tennessee got up there,
I am not here defending the legislature.
He didn't try to defend how Tennessee was counting or not counting. It's people.
He basically said, yeah, what we're doing is bad,
but it's nobody's job but ours to fix.
Is it worse for the legislature of Tennessee not to reapportion or is it worse
for the federal districts gorge violate the angel doc separation.
He basically said, if you step in,
you're going to screw up the balance of power in America.
The power in America comes from we, the people, not the courts.
So this matter should be left up to the people of Tennessee and their elected
representatives. Wait a second.
If the whole problem is that you don't have a voice in the legislature,
then how can you suddenly just have a voice in the legislature? I mean,
the only way to change it would be if the legislature itself were to give up
power. And why would they do that? Because of course,
once elected officials are in power,
they have a vested interest in keeping their districts exactly as they are,
because those were the districts that elected them.
And fundamentally,
electoral representatives knew that if they redrew the lines,
that they would be, um,
voting themselves out of political power.
That Ski Charles Professor Duke Law School.
So they had an incentive not to do anything about this.
So for the liberals on the court,
they felt like this was a fundamental flaw in our democracy that needed to be
fixed and nobody was going to fix it. They didn't fix it. But for Frankfurter,
he's like, if you fix this one, you're gonna have to fix it.
That one and that one and that one. And that one. And where's it going?
If you do this, there is no way out.
[inaudible]
the court's going to get stuck in what he called [inaudible]
political thicken. Ah,
the political thicken of the court must not enter the political thicket.
That sounds like Frankfurt. He must've written those words.
And the imagery at the thicket is that, uh, you know,
the dear very proudly with his new horns goes into the thicket,
gets entangled and can never get out.
Frank for years, claim was once the courts are in,
there will be nothing beyond it and someday the courts will be forced to declare
winners and losers. A very high profile elections.
[inaudible]
okay, so after the oral arguments are over in Baker vs Carr,
that justice is headed to conference. That's a meeting with just the nine.
And when they went into the conference,
basically the court would divide right down the middle.
And Charles Whitaker, he was a potential swing vote. Whitaker was deeply torn
[inaudible].
He'd been leaning Frankfurter's way,
but if there is a clear constitutional right that's being violated
during those first, that first argument,
he asked a number of questions that suggested a great deal of sympathy with the
plaintiff.
Sam Is there not
power and duty in the court to enforce that constitutional rights?
There was a lot of thought that he might actually come down on the side of,
of the plaintiffs in that case. I think that's where frank for to really,
really begin to, to rip into him
Justice Frankfurter right after the first oral argument during the conference,
even 90 minutes speech, so talked for 90 plus straight minutes,
darting around the room, pulling books off the shelves,
holing books off the shelf,
reading from prior cases gesticulating wildly to make his point and the whole
time looking directly at Whitaker.
There was one account that I heard where frankfurter went on for four hours,
four hours
lecturing, widowed. Really, really belittling him.
Oh, this guy.
Yes it was. It was horribly intimidating.
Um,
at one point, one of the justices on the liberal side, Justice Hugo black,
he took Whitaker aside,
black was trying to make him feel better and black said to Charles Whittaker,
just remember we're all boys grown tall.
Um,
we're not the gods who sit on high and dispense justice,
but it's very difficult not to see yourself in that role,
particularly if your vote might be the vote that decides everything.
This started to weigh heavily on Whitaker's mind.
[inaudible]
he was disturbed by the,
by having the way to the supreme court on his shoulders,
according to his family, Kate and Ken, my mother tells me that, you know,
he at that time was under a lot of stress and spoke as though he worked
dictating, spoke his punctuation.
Hello Judith Comma, it's very nice to meet you, period.
Clearly thinking about everything that he might say being recorded.
I remember his stating that it felt like all the words that he ordered were
being jeweled in stone as a result of Wiki said you don't talk much.
[inaudible]
so after they heard the case, the first time would occur,
couldn't make up his mind. And actually incidentally,
there was another justice justice Stewart who was the other swing vote in the
case, who also couldn't make up as mind.
Okay.
The court decided to hear the case again in the fall just because they needed
more time and over the summer. Interesting enough we did.
Chris said he remained deeply divided that he'd actually written memos on both
sides of the issue. Doug Smith says,
Whittaker wrote both an opinion for intervening and bigger versus car and a
dissent against intervening and bigger versus car at the same time.
Meanwhile, as he's doing this,
justice frankfurters circulated a 60 page memo explaining how this was a
political question that should not be decided by the courts. He's got, you know,
a fire in his belly. He's not gonna let it
this one go number six,
Charlotte is deputy baker now or tell him
Monday, October 9th,
1961 it's 10:00 AM and the court is back in session. Please. Of course,
the lawyer arguing the case against the Tennessee legislature begins,
Tennessee voters seek federal court protection.
Frankfurter sits quietly for about five minutes listening without the light.
And then
you don't need to imply, they call it referred to the wrong
[inaudible] right from the [inaudible]. And then I met suggested, right,
the ratio you gave a minute ago. I tried again.
[inaudible] trying to deal with that.
[inaudible] doesn't include any stated you would be different from you in much
worse when it's passed on it by denying or right under it,
it's better than passing on it. I don't know what is bad thing. Of course.
Not Mr. Justice Frank Murder
Frankfurter hammers the attorneys with questions during the course of oral
arguments. He speaks approximately 170 times 170,
170. Damn Charles Whittaker.
Please have some system for the allocation of its legislate doors to districts
or account
17 times.
Well, uh, basically
after nearly four hours of oral arguments,
the justice is
recess and go into conference. Frankfurter needed desperately.
He had a good Winokur and he would kept after him like a dog after a bone trying
to persuade them and that harassing he got, I have to make a point here.
It was a nightmare and I saw the nightmare.
How so? Describe it to me. Well, he was
a nervous wreck and like a cat on a hot tin roof. I found out,
I don't know if he told me or his wife told me he was on tranquilizers to try to
overcome what he thought was just work related stress. Well,
clearly something was taking hold of him who had trouble concentrating.
Highly fraught.
I would characterize his eventual breakdown is something of a slow descent.
By the early spring after the cord had returned from its winter recess,
a Whitaker was absent from the court.
You mean like he just didn't, he didn't show for work one day apparently.
So it's clerks didn't know where he was. Um,
the other justices didn't know his whereabouts.
He just disappeared really in the middle of what's going to become one of the,
you know, monumental decisions of the 20th century. He disappears.
He had to escape. Where'd he go? Well,
he went to really,
what would be a cabin in the woods in the middle of Wisconsin.
And
he,
he called up one of his former law associates in Kansas City to come up and join
him.
And according to Craig Smith, he in this guy whose name was Sam Mobi,
they would just sit there on the bank of the lake
in silence.
They would sit for hours on end, not talking to each other,
just waiting for the justice to speak,
no call our pride and what has happened. And so,
you know, we have no way of knowing what he was thinking at that moment.
But I imagine he was just sitting there and he was thinking about these things,
realities that could unfold. Like on the one hand,
if the court stepped into politics, they could protect people. No, mom,
Alabama,
the camera side.
[inaudible]
but on the other hand, it's gonna precedent with this said, it's a sad deal.
Mr President when we can, would it make the court two powerful,
Richard Shiny versus Albert Gore,
in which case you have your bullshit people as received president of the United
States 200 matches. Mine went back and forth and back and forth,
well not sleeping.
And when Whitaker decided that he really had to get back to work,
then this protege would say to him,
no, just relax. Just take it easy and um,
get yourself together before you decide to go back.
After three weeks, justice Whitaker returns to DC back to Washington,
uh, for a few days.
That's Ken, Teagan, his son.
We found my father to be really in extremis a debate and I think a borderline
suicidal.
When you said he was suicidal, what do you mean
there?
There was an instance in which my brother found my father going upstairs to get
a shotgun.
A few days later, Charles Whittaker checks himself into a hospital.
There is some evidence that it was really justice Douglas who convinced Whitaker
to go to the hospital.
I do recall that I have a nervous breakdown.
That's justice. William Douglas again
and he was at Walter Reed Hospital and I've been up to see him.
She had been up to see him
and uh,
[inaudible] wasn't very poor, physical condition,
very worried and very depressed.
I thought he should do.
I told him I didn't think he was being in a position to decide what he should do
until I get well.
A few weeks later,
March 29 1960 to the presidential press conference from the new State Department
Auditorium, Washington d c several announcements to make.
It is with extreme regret that I announced three time out of associate justice
of the Supreme Court, Charles Evans,
Whitaker effective April 1st justice Whitaker,
I remember of the Supreme Court for nearly five years and of the federal
judiciary.
Vanilli eight years is retiring the written direction of his position for
reasons of disability.
I know that the bench and the bar of the entire nation join me in commending Mr.
Justice Whitaker for his devoted service to his country during a critical period
and its history. Next,
I want to take this opportunity to stress again the importance of the tax bill.
Now before the House of Representatives.
Wow. Just being made
and whatever happened with the case with Descovy, well,
Whitaker didn't vote on bigger versus car.
So you could say that this case that essentially broke him,
his vote didn't count. Wow. Right around the time that he was in the hospital,
there was sort of this liberal coup at the court where Frankfurt or lost a
couple of other votes. So in the end,
the decision actually wasn't very close at all. What was it?
It was six to ah, Frankie. Yeah.
And Brennan wrote the majority opinion and he says that this whole kind of
cluster that we've been fighting over of how states in Tennessee count their
voters that this is something that courts can and should look at.
So in other words, I decided to lower their Ahrens and go into the thicket.
Oh yeah, they did.
Yay. In just one or two final questions. Um,
what happened to Justice Frankfurter? Well,
the the thing that I find perhaps most extraordinary is it less than two weeks
after the decision in Baker vs Carr came down,
Felix Frankfurter was working at his desk at the Supreme Court
and Frankfurter Secretary found him sprawled on the floor of his office from a
stroke.
He suffered a massive stroke and then never returned to service,
and while he was in the hospital solicitor general,
Archibald Cox visited Frankfurter and Frankfurter, he,
he was in a wheelchair and could barely speak,
but he apparently conveyed to Archibald Cox that the decision maker versus car
had essentially caused his stroke.
He felt so passionately that the court should stay out of the case that he
physically physically deteriorated after the court had gone the other way.
[inaudible]
after Baker versus Carr,
President Kennedy essentially had two Supreme Court vacancies to fill now
Whittaker seat.
He filled with a guy who turned out to be a moderate frankfurters vacancy.
That second vacancy, it's
that vacancy that will lead to the appointment of a man named Arthur Goldberg.
That is the fifth vote that the four liberals would are regarded as the four
liberals.
That becomes the fifth vote that they need really to create what has come to be
regarded as the Warren court revolution.
[inaudible]
this is when the supreme court basically became an agent for social change.
That revolution that begins with the 1962 term.
That's the revolution that is going to change [inaudible] at one man,
one vote, the way, withdraw our political boundaries.
Then the prosecutor withheld,
hey and fashion the way we think of criminal justice,
where small black armband, the way we treat first amendment,
religious education, religious and obscenity issues.
That's the war in court that people remember.
And that's the court that came into existence when Felix Frankfurter left.
And so just thinking about that question that,
that woman asked all the way at the beginning of this story. Yes. Could you, um,
address what I see is the, uh,
increasing politicization of the court,
the apotheosis of which I guess was, uh, you know,
voting or electing Bush to be our president.
You can kind of draw a line from this moment in Baker versus Carr all the way to
December 9th, 2000
block here in the east. The polls in six new states have just closed.
And the lead story at this hour is the state of Florida is too close to call.
I think folks from from with would've said C. And what we found was,
that's what I told you. That's what would happen is that eventually you will,
you will be deciding a partisan question,
which presidential candidate essentially received the most votes for those who
felt themselves on the losing side of push core.
This was just this Frankfurter's revenge.
This was the moment that a Baker v Carr had opened up.
And when I teach this to students, uh,
and particularly in the decade after Bush rigour when, uh, the,
the, the center sent to Ben Sentiments about this were still quite raw.
I would say to them, well, is this was frankfurter, right?
And I remember a student, uh, in the mid two thousands who said, uh,
in class, I never thought I would say this,
but because I hated the outcome and pushed freak or I was so angry when the
court interceded.
But if push free gores the price we have to pay for the courts,
making the overall political system work somewhat more tolerably properly,
it's a price I'm willing to pay.
Okay.
Before we totally sign off what happened at Douglas,
we sort of lost track of him. So after Baker versus Carr was decided,
he went on to be a supreme court justice for 13 more years. And to this day,
he actually
holds the record for being the longest serving justice of all time, 36 years.
And Frankfurter.
So Baker versus Carr was the last case that he ever heard and he died a few
years afterwards. And Charles would occur. Did he ever recovered? Well,
after Whitaker retired from the court,
he moved back to Kansas City with his family and his son said that it took them
about two years to get better from his nervous breakdown, but he did get better.
And eventually he got a job as counsel to General Motors,
but he never returned to the bench. He never was a judge again.